aber benimmst du dich anders vor der tür
ist zu hause drastisch möchte nicht mehr
philipp zuhause sein
ich bin zauberhaft ich bin in jedem der
ein sauberes internet liebe es wird
darum ja seitdem ich dieses buch gelesen
habe fühlte ich mich wie die pest davor
dieses wort zu benutzen authentizität
ist ein begriff der ist so wahnsinnig
positiv besetzt wahrheit echtheit am
anfang dieses buches sagt er
wir müssen zu einer ganz radikal anderen
definition von authentizität kommen
authentizität kann sich nur so
definieren als die erwartung die jemand
hat stimmt überein mit dem was er waren
mit dem was erwartet dass du machst das
so kommt ja ich wegen eines koalitions
sie nehmen ein beispiel was schilling
auch nimmt wenn du sagst das ist ein
authentisches italienisches restaurant
genau dann sagst du nichts über das
restaurant entweder hat es pizza dann
sage ich es ist authentisch weil ich mir
vorstelle jedes italienische restaurant
muss eine pizza servieren oder es hat
keine pizza dann sage ich es ist wollte
authentisch weil in meiner vorstellung
gerade das spezielle italienisch ist
genau der punkt ist du sagst eigentlich
nichts über die sache oder die person
zum beispiel die du als authentisch
bezeichnet sondern mit die über deine
kulturellen gepflogenheiten über einen
sogenannten habitus über deine
erwartungen und mehr leistet dieser
begriff eigentlich nicht und was könnten
wir vielleicht stattdessen versuchen
dazu entschieden das finde ich auch sehr
schön das ist doch ein ein wundervoller
ab schon vorher sagt zum beispiel
professionalität der sagt nämlich wird
aus dem buch jesaja angeblich auf und
professionalität in diesem sinne wie
schilling bisher verwendet heißt es ist
eben einfach professionell dass man in
bestimmten situationen situations- und
kontext gebunden agiert im grunde
betrifft ist die frage von manieren wenn
du mir auf den fuß tritt also
versehentlich natürlich für den teilort
versehentlich tritt und dann sagst es
tut mir wahnsinnig leid und ich sage
obwohl es wahnsinnig weh tut was macht
nichts dann ist das nicht authentisch
das ist kein authentisches bild auch
dass es tut mir wahnsinnig leid
eigentlich ihre und ich würde sagen es
tut mir überhaupt nicht leid aber der
umstand dass wir uns nicht authentisch
bin
in diesem fall zum beispiel sorgt dafür
dass sowas wie zusammenleben oder
zivilisation überhaupt möglich wird also
philipp ist für mich insofern
authentisch
du bist für mich schon authentisch
weiter zudem stehst was du denkst und
das merkt man auch auch wider willen
du sagst einfach was du denkst das
klingt für dich oft so aber da kann ich
dir versichern dass ich noch ungefähr 90
prozent dessen was ich auch noch sein
laptop aufwärts nichts sage
diese sprechen sich die ganze zeit über
mich in diesem clip es kapiert
authentisch oder nicht authentisch was
findet denn ihr ist authentisch etwas
gutes oder etwas schlechtes als
eigenschaft
[Musik]